bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france après le premier
continent le taux d'occupation des
prisons il était passé en dessous des
100% c'est une époque qui est déjà
révolu
comment s'explique cette augmentation
rapide on le rappelle depuis l'été 2000
20 en dix mois 6700 nouveaux détenus
écoutez nous on n en est pas trop étonné
parce que effectivement on a libéré
beaucoup de profits la petite pelle ou
proche de la sortie
pendant la crise inter et en masse la
problématique c'est que à l'époque on
avait des tribus manque était à l'arrêt
aujourd'hui il est rigoureux aux parts
et repartent
et ça veut dire que les peines suivantes
prennent leur tour et et il rentre en
détention et puis la plupart des
personnes qu'on a relâché sont déjà en
bon chez nous donc je pense que la
question à se poser
peut-être c'est pas le nombre de places
mais qu'est ce qui fait que les détenus
qui sortent euros viennent rapidement et
qu'il a le laxisme de la justice comme
l'ont fait d'ailleurs récemment les
policiers qui se sont mobilisés non mais
c'est plus du laxisme la c6 et si à un
moment donné
bien sûr qu'il faut respecter l'être
humain bien sûr qui entend tout ça je
suis tout à fait d'accord mais c'est une
des prisons et les centres et qu'on a
c'est la prison fait pas peur le
gendarme ne fait pas peur plus personne
fait peur on était kribi lisez par nos
politiques
on n'est pas soutenu par le garde des
sceaux
notre cargaison aujourd'hui qui
administre des détenus et non pas un
ministre de ses soldats qui seront quand
même
l'administration pénitentiaire et tous
les fonctionnaires qui travaillent là
dessus on est complètement lâchée par
votre administration quoi et aujourd'hui
on avance plus les détenus ont des
droits
puis son bien et tant mieux qu'il soit
bien mais ça marche pas ça marche pas à
la réinsertion ne fonctionne pas puis on
leur donne plus ils veulent ils sont
bien et puis vite y reviennent donc jeu
tandis qu'un moment de vous demander
quoi une réponse pénale a plus plus
sévère gesbert
ça va être pareil la prison fait pas
peur
tu sévère on va en danger les prisons
plus longtemps il faudrait peut-être
travailler sur autre chose
travail sur en amont avant de rentrer en
prison aujourd'hui on a des détenus par
exemple mineurs qui sont sensibles et
qui rentre on a de plus en plus et ce
cas pas un problème finalement est ce
que il faut pas mettre quelque chose en
place une et à un meilleur avant la
prison je sais pas je m'interroge par
exo jour d'hui exemple est à moi qu'il
faudrait il mettre en place je sais pas
faut trouver une solution déjà beaucoup
nos mineurs ils soient réinsérées il pas
une fois qu'ils sortent de prison
mineurs jeu majeur bien sûr parce
qu'aujourd'hui on prenait détenus ils
font un an deux ans trois ans de prison
en tout cas le pen france immowan ans et
on les remet dans leur cité dans leur
environnement
qu'est ce qui fonde et recommence ils
sont bien dans leur environnement qui
emplissent quand il rentre en prison
il faut des connaissances ils se font un
réseau qui s'élargissent et puis font
des bêtises encore plus con c'est pour
os
donc le problème c'est peut-être autre
chose
faut vraiment donné il faut arrêter de
regarder les conditions d'études des
détenus sont super bien traitée en
prison
alors je n'oublie pas comment je sais
pas où justement à propos de
l'environnement à carcéral la
construction annoncée de 15 mille
nouvelles places de prison fait débat
pour certains c'est une solution pour
d'autres c'est coûteux inefficace vous
en pensez quoi
alors faut savoir danser 15 mai place
qui a déjà deux mille places qui
construit et 5000 qui sont livrés pour
2022 normalement donc c'est pas du
présent elles sont nécessaires
on a des peines en attente on la
surpopulation qui varient actuellement
et merci à la crise à une guerre qui a
fait qu'on a un taux qui a bien diminué
donc on retourne aux trois prix 35e'
115% surpopulation carcérale
donc on va dire comment être parce que
les chips je n'utilise pas le jour à
l'autre c'est complètement aléatoire
mais les personnes nécessaires mais la
prison ne fait pas peur on va les
quartiers et dans 5 ans dans dix ans on
a le même problème ou même bien avant
d'avoir construit ses 15000 places
on aura le problème quoi qu'il arrive
parce que la solution c'est pas de faire
des places où on est bien
la prison c'est fait pour punir ces
faits pour sanctionner c'est fait pour
on n'a pas envie d'y revenir normalement
la prison on n'a pas envie d'y aller
et aujourd'hui on voit les mêmes
personnes qui viennent qui repartent en
permanence donc yens question c'est
vraiment à se poser dix-sept
associations et organisations à vous
l'avez entendu ont appelé à la
mobilisation citoyenne pour exhorter
emmanuel macron à passer de la parole
aux actes et en finir avec la
surpopulation carcérale
qu'attendez vous concrètement et puis
par ailleurs à moins d'un an de la
présidentielle est ce que sa mère est
très justement que ce soit un sujet
phare de la campagne présidentielle à
venir ou là
vous savez on n'attend plus grand chose
de ce gouvernement qui nous a
complètement lâché celui ci celui d'un
ca et malheureusement attristé par la
manière dont on est considéré ces il n'y
a pas de mots il n'y a pas de mots on
était laissée à l'abandon quoi c'est un
jeu peut reprendre
des propos de l'ancienne garde des
sceaux vous qu'ils disaient que y'avait
pas besoin du bal pour être surveillant
que c'était un travail qui était à la
portée de tout le monde
aujourd'hui on a un nouveau garde des
sceaux qui se fait applaudir par les
détenus en prison et qui cas pas mais
qui a qui n'a pas une seule fois parlé
de ses fonctionnaires si ce n'est une
fois pour dire que on n'avait pas besoin
d'être augmentée
ben ok super l'avouer j'ai trouvé
beaucoup de personnels de ceux qui vont
venir travailler pour 1400 euros par
mois qui vont faire cracher dessus qui
concerne pas construire des prisons et
puis on embauche et des personnels qui
vont partir et revenir parce que les
fonctionnaires aujourd'hui chez nous ne
reste plus ils restent plus et je vous
donne un exemple on a des dossiers pour
partir dans les autres administrations
en mairie par exemple les fonctionnaires
ont essayé de faire valoir leurs droits
pour partir sur des mairie de leur
commune
on les bloque on les bloque et songer
car des recours auprès des tribunaux
administratifs pour pouvoir faire valoir
leurs droits c'est alors qu'on évoque
impunément c'est à dire que c'est le
c'est la justice qui se fait sa justice
cc voilà comment les traiter le
personnel aujourd'hui c'est un pur
scandale
vous parliez vous parlez de réinsertion
vous savez que l'ancien patron de la
police nationale pense mais qu'il ya
aussi un problème dans l'exécution des
peines en france cet accord avec les
jets problèmes d'exécution des peines
oui propres missions sûr et c'est pas en
inversant les processus qu'on va les
régler
ce qu'on nous dit il faut lever les
peines plancher il faut enlever les rib
le taux de réduction de peine ok et en
fait on va se revoir lors d'une
automatiquement
il leur anglais ont des comportements on
va leur donner au bon comportement juste
comme ça on aura dit monsieur dit pour
nous retire il a miné son nom quelque
part il aura fait quelque chose là il
aura quelque chose qui fera exactement
la même chose et on règle pas le
problème
et voilà c'est moi j'écoute je regarde
je dis je mais il ya rien ne l'ont pas
ils ont rien fait de bon y'a rien et
rien il y avait une cadence
on est au ralenti donc vous pour
terminer votre message vous dites qu'il
faut de la réinsertion c'est ça la
réinsertion
bien sûr qu'il faut essayer de réinsérer
et tous tous les détenus qu'on peut
réussir et ce soir du moins on ne pourra
jamais dire qu'on aura un taux de
prendre de même titre on attend de ces
comportements de bâtir sur ces faux ici
impossible c'est pas possible
mais sûr que tout ce qu'on pourra
insérer sera dupont met à c'est pas en
donnant tout et en donnant toutes les
possibilités et tout le confort possible
à une population pénale qu'on pourra
s'en sortir parce qu'on le fait on
avance et plus on avance et moins ça
marche
peut-être que vous me donnez pour aller
en marche arrière là où aller pour faire
marcher un peu mieux merci en tout cas
cyril huet lambine j'appelle quand vous
êtes délégué national adjoint du
syndicat pénitentiaire espèces